[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
friends families teachers class of 2018
wave in the cluster
[Applause]
what they don't tell you about class day
is how infinite it will feel how you'll
look around and lose yourself searching
for your junior year suite mates and
sophomore year crushes you'll hold up a
telescope and count the crazy hats like
they are stars like all the campus
constellations you once populated have
crossed together today here is the first
professor who made you feel like you
belonged here and the two friends who
walked you all the way back home that
one night even though they lived in TD
and the classmates who chanted with you
on cross campus and the suite mates who
stayed up so late with you roasting that
one he'll Daily News op-ed that you
skipped class the next day and your best
friend pursuing her passion for theater
next year at McKinsey and company
what they don't tell you about Woolsey
Hall is how quickly it can fill with joy
perhaps this campus felt hollow at first
like a thousand concentric orbits you
would never fit into until one day you
found yourself on a dance floor in l-dub
or in a junior seminar texting the
friend right next to you and now
laughing with upcoming speakers you hear
a heartbeat I imagine there's an
astrophysicist in another galaxy
watching us today there they are he will
say they made it to the middle how she
will see the way we are celebrating and
shining on this class day how she will
study the ways we keep our North Stars
near across the aisles today and across
the seas and States next year how she
will marvel at all the light from
Woolsey Hall and wonder what a universe
those kids built congratulations and
help me welcome up our class state
chairs Josh and Alexis
welcome class of 2018 today is a day of
celebration we'll listen to our
distinguished speaker hear about the
achievements of our brilliant classmates
and listen to contemplative reflections
from our peers will also celebrate a few
clash traditions watch a commemorative
class film and cheer on our peers who
receive awards most importantly we will
reminisce with our classmates about the
Yale memories that will last a lifetime
when I reflect on my own years here one
of the first things that comes to mind
is quite simply change for many of us
coming to Yale itself was a radical
change from the cultures and norms and
ideas we know from back home many of us
arrived to your freshman year wide-eyed
and bushy tailed thinking we had it all
figured out years later we know how much
bigger and more complicated the world
truly is before Yale I had never met so
many people who believed in certain
ideals that were different from my own
but after four years here I've learned
to open my mind to alternative
perspectives we all have different
beliefs and backgrounds but as jelly's
we all share a common identity one that
leads us to treat each other with
decency and respect this day is a day in
which we celebrate one another together
our program has been put together to
interweave the many faces and voices of
our class when we wave our white
handkerchiefs at the end of the program
we will do it together as Yale ease the
change that our class has experienced
extends beyond Yale our generation has
been defined by the capacity of our
technology and the incapacity of our
institutions by Fannie Mae Facebook and
Ferguson but just as our generation has
been defined by the world so will the
world be defined by our generation young
people are using our Civic power
students at Yale led by women of color
in this room
have demanded we achieve inclusion and
justice on our campus
youth from Baltimore to Parkland have
marched on Washington students across
borders and across communities possess a
unique audacity to reimagine the axes on
which our society spins all it takes for
this latent audacity to enflame is the
spark of injustice we've observed in our
textbooks and in our streets that only
daring dissent drives change we are
emboldened not deterred when we awake to
find that the world for which proceeding
advocates have fought is not yet won and
we are roused by the rhetoric of those
advocates like our guest speaker this
afternoon who told graduates at
Wellesley last year if you feel
powerless
don't Hillary Rodham Clinton served as
the 67th US Secretary of State from 2009
to 2013
she was a US senator from New York from
2001 to 2009 and she served as first
lady for eight years prior
Secretary Clinton received a BA from
Wellesley College and a JD from Yale Law
School
and if you haven't heard she is the
first woman to be nominated by a major
party for President of the United States
we welcome Secretary Clinton back to
Yale not simply because she served as a
senator or as Secretary of State we
welcome her because she has driven so
many of us to pursue the pads we've
chosen for ourselves because she reminds
us there is nobility and serving more
than oneself because of her successes
and her setbacks for in the words of
Theodore Roosevelt the credit belongs to
the man or woman who is actually in the
arena please join me in welcoming
Hillary Rodham Clinton
thank you very much
thanks everybody thank you thank you
thank you wow I am so delighted to be
here sorry we're not outside but this
makes it kind of cozy I want to thank
President Salva and Dean Chun thank you
Alex a Razorback fan from Little Rock
Arkansas for getting us started on such
a high note
thanks to Alexis and Josh for your
comments and your introduction thanks to
all of the family and friends here today
for allowing me to share this happy
occasion and good afternoon to everyone
joining us by live stream from around
campus but most of all congratulations
to the class of 2018 I am thrilled for
all of you even the three of you who
live in Michigan and didn't request your
absentee ballots in time
what
before I go any further I just want to
be sure did the students from the new
colleges make it here I worried that
your flights might be delayed sorry
Franklin and Paulie Marie I heard you at
a great first year and I am honored that
this class has invited me to be your
speaker now I see looking out at you
that you are following the tradition of
over-the-top hats so I brought a hat - a
[Applause]
[Music]
Russian hat
I mean if you can't beat them join them
now being here with you brings back a
flood of memories I remember the first
time I arrived on campus as an incoming
law student in the fall of 1969 wearing
my bell-bottoms driving a beat-up old
car with a mattress tied to the roof I
had no idea what to expect now to be
honest I had had some trouble making up
my mind between Yale and Harvard Law
School's
then one day while we were still in that
period of decision making I was invited
to a cocktail party at Harvard for
potentially incoming law students where
I met a famous law professor a friend of
mine a male law student introduced me to
this famous law professor I mean truly
big 3-piece suit watch-chain and my
friend said professor this is Hillary
Rodham she's trying to decide whether to
come here next year or sign up with our
closest competitor now the great man
gave me a cool dismissive look and said
well first of all we don't have any
close competitors
and secondly we don't need any more
women at Harvard
now I was leaning toward Yale anyway but
that pretty much sealed the deal and
when I came to Yale I was one of 27
women out of 235 law students it was the
first year women were admitted to the
college and as that first class of women
prepared to graduate four years later
the New York Times reported on Yale's
foray into co-education noting that the
women quote worked harder and got
somewhat better grades than the 940 men
graduating with them a fact they went on
to say that some of the men apparently
found threatening well I was shocked
but over the years Yale has been a home
away from home for me a place I've
returned to time and again I spoke to
class day back in 2001 on the 300th
anniversary of the University and I hope
that that will be the case for many of
you as well this school has been
responsible for some of my most
treasured friends and colleagues people
like Jake Sullivan and Harold Koh and
I've watched some of you grow up like
Rebecca Shaw who's graduating today and
you'll hear from shortly and I've been
honored to serve over the last year or
two working with some of the Yale Law
School faculty including the new dean
Heather gherkin
now Yale grads many of whom are also
here today have worked for me in the
United States Senate the State
Department on my presidential campaigns
and I have been so well served I have a
very dedicated campaign intern here
graduating David Shimer the class of
2018
but I have to confess of all the
formative experiences I had at Yale
perhaps none was more significant than
the day during my second year when I was
cutting through what was then the
student lounge with some friends and I
saw this tall handsome guy with a beard
who looked like a Viking I said to my
friend well who is that and she said
well that's Bill Clinton he's from
Arkansas and that's all he ever talks
about and then as if on cue I hear him
saying and not only that we grow the
biggest watermelons in the world and I
was like who is this person but you know
he kept looking at me and I kept looking
back and so we were in the wall library
one night I was studying but I couldn't
help but see you know occasionally as I
lifted my head up um that he was again
looking at me so finally I thought this
is ridiculous so I got up went over to
him and I said you're gonna keep looking
at me and I'm gonna keep looking back we
at least ought to be introduced I'm
Hillary Rodham who are you and that
started a conversation that continues to
this day
now it was also here at Yale that I saw
a flyer in the law school on a bulletin
board that changed my life now some of
your parents and grandparents may
remember flyers and bulletin boards for
the rest of you suffice it to say that
was how we got information it was like
Facebook but the bulletin board didn't
steal your personal information
[Applause]
so one day I saw a note about a woman
named Marian Wright Edelman at Yale Law
School graduate civil rights activist
who would go on to found the Children's
Defense Fund Marian was coming back to
campus to give a lecture I went I was
captivated to hear her talk about using
her Yale education to create a headstart
program in rural Mississippi and I wound
up working for her that summer and the
experienced opened my eyes to the ways
that the law can protect children or
come up short because like many of you I
learned just as much outside the four
walls of the classroom as I did sitting
in a lecture hall and I discovered a
passion that has animated my life and my
work ever since now a lot has changed
since I was here in 2019 Yale will
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
matriculation of women at the college
and the 150th anniversary of the first
women graduate students at Yale and I
heard that Yale officially changed the
term freshman to first-year I also heard
amazingly that the Dukes men and the
Whiffenpoofs have started welcoming
women now as for my long-lost
wyff's audition tape I have buried it so
deep not even WikiLeaks will be able to
find it
because if you thought my emails were
scandalous you should hear my singing
voice
I find it very exciting that today's
graduates hail from all 50 states the
District of Columbia Puerto Rico Guam
and 56 other countries and in your four
years on campus you've survived late
nights and the best cubicles and early
mornings and the Sterling stacks you've
trekked up Science Hill maybe you've
even found love at the Last Chance dance
and now you're ready to take on your
next adventure but maybe some of you are
reluctant to leave I understand that
it's possible to feel both because the
class of 2018 is graduating at one of
the most tumultuous times in the history
of our country and I say that as someone
who graduated in the 60s I recently went
back and looked up those famous lines
from Charles Dickens in A Tale of Two
Cities because you know I usually end
after saying it was the best of times it
was the worst of times
but it goes on it was the age of wisdom
it was the age of foolishness it was the
epoch of belief it was the epoch of
incredulity it was the season of light
it was the season of darkness it was the
spring of hope it was the winter of
despair
now Dickens was writing about the years
leading up to the French Revolution but
he could have been describing the
ricocheting highs and lows of this
moment in America we're living through a
time when fundamental rights civic
virtue freedom of the press even facts
and reason are under assault like never
before but we are also witnessing an era
of new moral conviction civic engagement
and a sense of devotion to our democracy
and country so here's the good news if
any group were ever prepared to rise to
the occasion it is you the class of 2018
you've already demonstrated the
character and courage that will help you
navigate this tumultuous moment and most
of all you've demonstrated resilience
now that's a word that's been on my mind
a lot recently one of my personal heroes
Eleanor Roosevelt said you gain strength
courage and confidence by every
experience in which you really stop to
look fear in the face you are able to
say to yourself I have lived through
this or I can take the next thing that
comes along
well that's resilience and it's so
important because everyone everyone gets
knocked down what matters is whether you
get back up and keep going
this may be hard for a group of yale
soon-to-be graduates to accept but yes
you will make mistakes in life you will
even fail
it happens to all of us no matter how
qualified or capable we are take it from
me
Wow I remember those first months after
that 2016 election we're not easy we all
had our own methods of coping I went for
long walks in the woods
Yale students went for long walks in
East Rock Park I spent hours going down
a Twitter rabbit hole you spent hours in
the Yale memes group I had my fair share
of Chardonnay you had penny drinks at
woods
I practice yoga and alternate nostril
breathing
you took psych and the good life and let
me just get this out of the way no I'm
not over it I still think about the 2016
election I still regret the mistakes I
made
I still think though that understanding
what happened in such a weird and wild
election in American history will help
us defend our democracy in the future
with your right left center Republican
Democrat independent vegetarian whatever
we all have a stake in that so today as
a person I'm okay
but as an American I'm concerned you
know personal resilience is important
but it's not the only form of resilience
we need right now we also need community
resilience that's something that this
class has embodied during your time on
campus literally at times like in the
march of resilience your sophomore year
it was the biggest demonstration
the biggest demonstration in the history
of the school that's 300 plus years led
by women of color supported by students
and faculty determined to make Yale a
more just equitable and safe place for
everyone
many of you have said that March was a
defining moment in your college
experience and that says something about
this class and your values because the
truth is our country is more polarized
than ever we have sorted ourselves in
two opposing camps and that divides how
we see the world the data backs this up
there are more liberals and
conservatives than there used to be and
fewer centrists our political parties
are more ideologically and
geographically consistent which means
there are fewer northern Republicans and
fewer Southern Democrats and the divides
on race and religion are starker than
ever before and as the middle shrink
partisan animosity grooved now I'm not
going to get political here but this
isn't simply a both sides problem the
radicalization of American politics
hasn't been symmetrical there are
leaders in our country who blatantly
incite people with hateful rhetoric who
fear change who see the world in
zero-sum terms so that if others are
gaining well they must be losing that's
a recipe for polarization and conflict
our social fabric is fraying and the
bonds of community that hold us together
are fractured this isn't just a problem
because it leads to unpleasant
conversations over the Thanksgiving
dinner table it's a problem because it
undermines the Civic spirit that makes
democracy possible the habits of the
heart that de Tocqueville found so
unique in the American character I
believe healing our country is going to
take what I call radical empathy
as hard as it is this is a moment to
reach across divides of race class and
politics to try to see the world through
the eyes of people very different from
ourselves and to return to rational
debate to find a way to disagree without
being disagreeable to try to recapture a
sense of community and common humanity
when we think about politics and judge
our leaders we can't just ask am I
better off than I was two years or four
years ago we have to ask are we all
better off are we as a country better
stronger and fairer that's something
you've done here at Yale you've learned
that you don't need to be an immigrant
to be outraged when a classmate's father
a human being who contributes to his
family and his country is unjustly
deported you don't need to be a person
of color to understand that when black
students feel singled out and targeted
we still have work to do and you don't
need to experience gun violence to know
that when a teenager in Texas who just
survived a mass shooting says she's not
surprised by what happened at her school
because and I quote I've always felt
like eventually it was going to happen
here too
we are failing our children so enough is
enough we need to come together and we
certainly need common-sense gun safety
legislation as soon as we can get it
now
empathy should not only be at the center
of our individual lives our families and
our communities it should be at the
center of our public life our policies
and our politics I know we don't always
think of politics and empathy as going
hand-in-hand but they can and more than
that they must as former secretary
Madeleine Albright writes and her
terrific new book fascism a warning
she says this generosity of spirit this
caring about others and about the
proposition that we are all created
equal is the single most effective
antidote to the self-centered moral
numbness that allows fascism to thrive
and of course Madeleine had personal
experience fleeing the Nazis in
Czechoslovakia as a baby returning after
the war fleeing the Communists as a
young girl now that brings me to one
more form of resilience that's been on
my mind over the last year Democratic
resilience in 1787 after the
Constitutional Convention in
Philadelphia Benjamin Franklin who by
the way received an honorary degree from
Yale was asked by a woman in the street
outside Independence Hall well doctor
what have we got a republic or a
monarchy and Franklin answered a
republic if you can keep it right now
we're living through a full-fledged
crisis in our democracy now there are
not tanks in the streets but what's
happening right now goes to the heart of
who we are as a nation and I say this
not as a Democrat who lost an election
but as an American afraid of losing a
country there are certain things that
are so essential they should transcend
politics waging a war on the rule of law
and a free press delete' amaizing
elections perpetrating shameless
corruption and rejecting the idea that
our leaders should be public servants
undermines our national you know
and attacking truth and reason evidence
and facts should alarm us all you and
your parents have just paid for a
first-class world-class education and as
Yale history professor Timothy Snyder
writes in his book on tyranny to abandon
facts is to abandon freedom if nothing
is true then no one can criticize power
because there is no basis upon which to
do so if nothing is true then all is
spectacle I think professor Schneider
both in that book and in his new one the
road to unfreedom is sounding the alarm
as loudly as he can because attempting
to erase the line between fact and
fiction truth and reality is a core
feature of authoritarianism the goal is
to make us question logic and reason and
to sow mistrust toward exactly the
people we need to rely on our leaders
the press experts who seek to guide
public policy baked-on based on evidence
even ourselves just this week former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said if
our leaders seek to conceal the truth or
we as people become accepting of
alternative realities that are no longer
grounded in facts then we as American
citizens are on a pathway to relinquish
ITAT late but he's absolutely right so
how do we build democratic resilience I
think it starts with standing up for
truth facts and reason not just in the
classroom and on campus but every day in
our lives it means speaking out about
the vital role of higher education in
our society to create opportunity and
equality it means calling out actual
fake news when we see it and supporting
brave journalists and their reporting
maybe even by subscribing to a newspaper
now most of all as obvious as it seems
it means voting in every election not
just at the presidential ones so yes
these are challenging times for America
but we've come through challenging times
before you know I think back to the
night Barack Obama was elected president
many of us so many of us were jubilant
even I who had once hoped to beat him
was estatic it was such a hopeful moment
and yet in some ways this moment feels
even more hopeful because this is a
battle-hardened hope tempered by loss
and clear-eyed about the stakes we are
standing up to policies that hurt people
we are standing up for all people being
treated with dignity we are doing the
work to translate those feelings into
action and the fact that some days it is
really hard to keep at it just makes it
that much more remarkable that so many
of us are in fact keeping at it it's not
easy to wade back into the fight every
day but we're doing it and that's why I
am optimistic because of how
unbelievably tough Americans are proving
to be I've encountered lots of people in
recent months who give me hope the
Parkland students who endured
unthinkable tragedy and have responded
with courage and resolve the leaders and
groups I've gotten to know through
outward together an organization I
started after the election to encourage
the outpouring of grassroots engagement
that we're seeing everyone who is
marching registering voters and diving
into the issues facing us like never
before some for the very first time in
their lives and I find hope in the wave
of women running for office and winning
and hope in the women and men who are
dismantling the notion that women should
have to endure harassment and violence
as a part of our lives so we have a long
way to go
there are many fights to fight and more
seem to rise every day
it will take work to keep up the
pressure to stay vigilant
- neither close our eyes nor numb our
hearts or throw up our hands and say
someone else take over from here
because at this moment in our history
our country depends on every citizen
believing in the power of their actions
even when that power is invisible and
their efforts feel like an uphill battle
of every citizen voting in every
election even when your side loses it is
a matter of infinite faith this faith we
have in the ability to govern ourselves
to come together to make honourable
practical compromise in the pursuit of
ends that will lift us all up and move
us forward so yes we need to pace
ourselves but also lean on each other
look for the good wherever we can
celebrate heroes and courage children
find ways to disagree respectfully we
need to be ready to lose some fights
because we will as John McCain recently
reminded us no Just Cause is futile even
if it's lost what matters what matters
is to keep going no matter what keep
going
the Yale your graduating from is very
different from the Yale I graduated from
it's different even from the Yale that
welcomed you four years ago four years
ago not one of Yale's colleges was named
after a woman today's students are
carrying on the legacy of a trailblazing
LGBT civil rights activist at Pauli
Murray College and celebrating one of
Yale's own hidden figures at Grace
Hopper college named after the naval
officer who happened to be one of the
first computer programmers in America
those changes didn't happen on their own
you made them possible you kept fighting
you kept the faith and because of that
in the end you changed Yale as much as
Yale changed you and now it's time
for you to make your mark on the world I
know the best the best for you for Yale
and for America is yet to come and you
each will have a role to play and a
contribution to make thank you and
congratulations to the class of 2018
[Applause]
Secretary Clinton thank you so much for
honoring us today your distinguished
service has made the world better for
all especially the vulnerable and today
your words have inspired this
outstanding group of young leaders to
continue your honorable work I have a
few announcements to make first
I apologize that The Weather Channel got
hacked by the Russians but first I do
want to thank you all students and
guests for your really gracious
understanding about the weather
situation and forecast preparations for
this event required us to make a
decision yesterday or risk the event
being canceled all together and so not
wanting to bear that risk we move the
venue here I hope all of you have found
this a good viewing place for the event
unfortunately tomorrow's weather looks
really really good okay I do have some
other business to share with you but
first I need to ask the following
students to come up to the seats in the
front row over here so so when I call
out your name please start coming up
over here
Jen Berkowitz of sabra college
joonyoung's will of sabra college
joonyoung schewe of saber college your
letter will give it I'll give you a
chance to cheer later he IDs tapana
Pearson college marry Chandler Gwyn of
saber College
lion-o Jin of Grace Hopper college
Halley Meccano krutiov Timothy Dwight
college Martin Lim of Berkeley College
erica lynn green of Grace Hopper college
[Applause]
Maisie Louise Mattia of Branford College
been Reeves of Berkeley College Patrick
Sullivan of Jonathan Edwards College
so as you come up we also have another
thing for all of us we need to do a
little dress rehearsal for tomorrow at
commencement on old campus in sunny
weather there's going to be a point
where I stand up on the podium in front
of president Salome and present you to
him so that you can receive your degrees
so there's a there's a part for you to
play the last two sentences of my
request to president salivate are going
to be as follows they have been
recommended by the Faculty of Yale
College and approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees okay and
those are the two key words these
degrees because when you hear those two
words confer upon them these degrees I
want you to be excited about that and
and show the university and all your
guests how excited that you are about
graduating so we'll get to practice a
little bit here so I'm gonna just read
out that quote and when I say these
degrees you kind of you know do your
thing
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
I think you can do better than that
we'll try again I'll weed out the
sentence and then let's see what you can
remember our old campus is really big so
it's not going to be as as equius as
this room is so let's try this again
pretender on old campus okay they have
been recommended by the Faculty of Yale
College and approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
okay great okay I think we're ready I
look forward to see oh I'll be coming up
again but thank you congratulation class
of 2018 you were the most highly
decorated class in the history of Yale
athletics
I would like to ask Jen Berkowitz and
Ben Reeves to please come to the stage
[Applause]
it is my honor to award to the female
and male outstanding athlete the Nellie
Elliot award for the female in the
William Mallory award for the male
gender quits
the Nellie Elliot award winner is a
first-team all Ivy selection she's a
leading scorer and rebounder on the Yale
team for the past two years 1,000 points
scorer had the best field goal
percentage in the Ivy League for the
past two years she's helped the Yale
team to the best season in school
history the Bulldogs won this year's
Women's Basketball Invitational the
first postseason championship ever in
the Ivy League Jen is an honors student
in pre-med and plans to go to medical
school congratulations Jen
the William Mallory Award winner Ben
leaves is the leading scorer in the
hundred plus year history of Yale
lacrosse he's the captain of the team
he's a first-team All Ivy performer for
three consecutive years and was twice
the Ivy League Player of the Year he's a
finalist three consecutive years for the
to Orton award which is the nation's
best player he is led Yale to 49 wins
the most ever he is an honors student as
well in molecular cellular developmental
biology but before he begins that next
chapter in his life he and his teammates
will be heading to the national
championship the Final Four at Gillette
Stadium in Foxborough Massachusetts
congratulations Ben
yeah
could you please stay standing for one
more minute in honor of your 24 years of
service to Yale we have a special
tribute for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vetti Esteban and
and Haley Meccano Kushi please come up
to the stage
the nakanishi prize is awarded to two
graduating seniors who while maintaining
high academic achievement have provided
exemplary leadership in enhancing race
or ethnic relations at Yale College
this year's prizes are awarded to Eddie
Estefan of Pearson college and hailey
Meccano Khushi of timothy dwight college
Evette es de pon is a fierce advocate
for justice whose scholarship and
service cut across lines of racial and
ethnic identity as a double major in
african-american studies and ethnicity
race and migration
Evette II has explored afro-latin ex
identity and patterns of migration in
the Caribbean as one of the head
organizers for next Yale she helped plan
the march of resilience in fall of 2015
bringing together the Yale community to
focus on solidarity unity and student
impact and as a multicultural peer
liaison co-head peer liaison an
intersectionality committee chair for
both the afro-american cultural center
and lacasa
she has mentored her younger peers as
they navigated their own pathways
through Yale she has already received
multiple awards and now to recognize
these accomplishments Yale College is
honored to bestow the NA Konishi prize
upon a vet est
halie mechanic Russia is a scholar and
leader who has advocated for her
Hawaiian community and for native voices
more broadly an ethnicity race and
migration major who has studied settler
colonialism in her home of Hawaii
she has engaged and challenged the Yale
community on issues of cultural
appropriation she has written about the
experiences of American Indians and
Pacific Islanders and she has brought a
global perspective on colonialism and
indigeneity to the Native American
cultural center as the president of the
Association of Native Americans at Yale
Haley revived the Yale powwow after a
10-year dormancy establishing it as an
annual event and she hosted the Henry
Rho cloud alumni conference bringing
generations of Native alumni back to
Yale after graduation she will pursue a
PhD in American Studies at Brown
University
for these contributions and for her
commitment to this community Yale
College is honored to bestow the
nakanishi Prize upon Haley Meccano
Khushi
Patrick Sullivan will you please come up
to the stage
the James Andrew Haas prize is awarded
annually to that member of the senior
class in Yale College whose breadth of
intellectual achievement strength of
character and fundamental humanity shall
be adjudged by the faculty to have
provided leadership for his or her
fellow students inspiring in them a love
of learning and concern for others this
year the Haas Prize is awarded to
Patrick Sullivan of Jonathan Edwards
College
[Applause]
Patrick Sullivan graduates with
distinction in his major American
Studies a communication and consent
educator a foot leader and at Whitehall
urban fellow he has devoted himself
through critical inquiry and
communication to promoting an equitable
Society he has served with the Yale
undergraduate prison project for four
years tutoring and mentoring
incarcerated people and he has
co-founded the Connecticut bail bond
fund to address injustice in the
criminal system the first of its kind in
Connecticut and one of the few models of
bail relief in the nation after
graduation Patrick will continue this
work expanding the program around the
country for his outstanding academic
achievements and his impressive record
of public service and commitment to
prison reform Yale College is proud to
bestow the James Andrew Haas Memorial
Prize upon Patrick Kirkham Sullivan
[Applause]
but the first time this past August I
walked through the heavy gates of the
towering red brick and stone castle on
Prospect Street into the lush green
courtyard of my new home Pauli Murray
College here I was given a chance at
recreating my life at Yale as a
first-year I often felt alone for the
first time in my life I grew sharply
aware of my difference but this year was
different now as a first year counselor
in Pauli Murray's inaugural year I was
charged with creating a home for first
years that would welcome them for who
they are I exchanged a regret I felt in
years past for newfound hope the hope
that my Frodo team and I would shape
Pauli Murray into the home we've always
wanted I tried to imagine how Pauli
Murray would tackle this challenge
Murray defied state segregation laws by
sitting at the front of public buses she
coined the term Jane crow to describe
the unfair treatment she received at
Howard Law where she was the only woman
in her entire class Murray was a woman's
rights activist a poet a civil rights
organizer an Episcopal priest and the
first African American woman turned a JD
at Yale Law her multifaceted identity
gave her a keen ability to
simultaneously experience differences
and connections among the communities
she inhabited she argued that true
community is based on upon equality
mutuality and reciprocity it affirms the
richness of individual diversity as well
as a common human ties that binds us
together Murray broke barriers to create
a home for the marginalized in the
United States I wanted to do the same in
my new college my Foucault's team
consisted of a math whiz two whiffs a
future Hollywood film director a
political philosopher and me the son of
two teachers a Texan and a Mexican
immigrant who sacrificed it all to send
their kid to the Ivy League
we decided that when the first years
arrived we would help them explore their
differences by encouraging them to tell
their stories rather than papering over
them for the sake of comfort the first
two weeks of school we awkwardly sat in
a circle each night for our nightly fro
Co meetings and we soon realized that
our kids came from all over the world
from unique families who each quirky in
their own ways some of them spoke with a
southern twang others until West Coast
lingo the next meeting they each wrote
down anonymously their greatest
anxieties about the new year and past
they're no cards around for their peers
to read many of these anxieties were
informed by their divergent personal
experiences but by articulating and not
shying away from these differences they
understood their peers for the complex
human beings they are they also realized
that in spite of their differences many
of them shared the same fears yes they
were different but in many ways they
were also the same though the work
required to build true community may be
daunting at times we learned that it is
worth it because the outcome
is harmony I felt harmony when the
throat goes and I gathered the first
years in the courtyard to share the new
college chance they created we proudly
shouted into the air but would some day
become tradition then we linked arms and
cheered Marie's name now this feeling is
not unique to our College I'm sure you
felt it too
running behind your flag on old campus
in first year's Olympics and the
collective breaths of musicians striking
their first note the silent hum of a
study group an intense focus or the
powerful rhythm of a team running in
unison participation in a community like
a residential college permanently
changes us our conversations extend the
scope of our perspective reveal new
possibilities of existence and showcase
the richness of our reality the
alternative to this all is disharmony
it's the discord we see in America today
as legislators and citizens alike cease
to listen or trust one another when our
stories fall on closed ears stereotypes
pervade fake news distorts our reality a
cacophony of screaming voices silences
reason the example of Mary's words in
the example of Mary College ought to
resonate in our hearts in a time in
which our country stands so divided we
must find what binds us and holds fast
to it wherever we end up we must build a
home with love curiosity and courage
thank you a class of 2018 and
congratulations
[Applause]
marry Chandler Gwyn and Maisy Lewis
Mattia could you please come up to the
stage
the Louis sutler prizes for excellence
in the Performing and creative arts are
awarded to two outstanding seniors marry
Chandler Gwyn of Sabra College and Maisy
nice Mattia
Branford please marry Chandler Gwyn is a
dancer and choreographer with
intelligence versatility and vision her
work has an intense quality of listening
she is a quiet observer of life's
rhythms with a deep understanding of
gesture known for her sensitivity and
receptivity toward all aspects of the
art and her fellow artists she sees and
uses dancers for who they are and how
they move she is also a scientist she
graduates [ __ ] laude with distinction in
her major molecular biophysics and
biochemistry and with her keen attention
to the details of phenomena that fall
beyond language she bridges science and
the arts the scientific laboratory and
the dance studio for her ambitious and
continually deepening body of dances and
for her future artistic promise Yale
College is delighted to award the Louise
Sadler prize for excellence in the
Creative and Performing Arts to marry
Chandler Quinn
do you Maisy Lewis Mattia is a writer
who majors in literature thinks about
literature dreams about literature and
will undoubtedly contribute to
literature one of our professors
describes her writing as dazzling in his
virtuosity complexity and originality
another calls it genuinely brilliant her
friends and teachers know me as someone
who has read everything who misses meals
because she has gotten caught up in a
book who when she talks about Virginia
Woolf makes you feel that Wolfe is not
just alive but is about to walk in just
about to walk into the room may who
graduates [ __ ] laude has already
completed two novels and next year she
will pursue an MFA in creative writing
at Hunter College for her exceptional
talent and her future promise Yale
College is delighted to award the Lewis
Adler prize for excellence in the
Creative and Performing Arts to Maisy
Lewis Mattia
[Applause]
Erica Eleanor Lin Green will you please
come up to the stage
the Warren Memorial High scholarship
prize for the senior majoring in the
humanities who ranks highest in
scholarship is awarded this year to
erica lynn green of grace hopper college
Erica Eleanor Lin Greene has balanced
her passion for the humanities with her
deep interest in bioethics and the
disparities in health and healthcare in
her role as the advocacy chair of the
Yale hunger and homeless Action project
she helped launch the founding team for
a yeild student-run youth shelter in New
Haven elected to Phi Beta Kappa in her
junior year miss Lynn Greene was awarded
a Marshall scholarship last December she
graduates summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in her major English she
will pursue degrees in global health
systems theory and policy as well as
development and global health at Queen
Mary University of London in recognition
of her extraordinary achievements Yale
College is proud to award the warren
Memorial High scholarship prize this
year to Erica Eleanor Lynn green
Martin Lim please come up to the stage
the Arthur twining Hadley prize which
honors the memory of the man who served
as president of Yale from 1899 to 1921
is awarded annually to the senior in
Yale College majoring in the social
sciences who ranks highest in
scholarship this year the Hadley Prize
is awarded to Martin Lim of Berkeley
College Martin Lim was elected to Phi
Beta Kappa in his junior year and
graduate summa [ __ ] laude with
distinction in both his majors economics
and chemistry he is also the recipient
of the Bishop Berkeley Prize given by
Berkeley College to the student who best
discovered the intellectual
potentialities of a university he has
served as a member of Berkeley College
Council as first year captain of
Berkeley intramurals and as Berkeley
College first-year counselor as a peer
tutor for the chemistry department he
has helped other Yale students succeed
and he has studied in Japan as a Richard
light fellow he has served his country
holding the rank of Corporal first class
as a combat engineer in the Singapore
Armed Forces to recognize his academic
Intel excellence Yale College proudly
awards the Arthur twining Hadley prize
to Martyn Lim
lyonell Jin will you please come up to
the stage
the rustle the rustle Henry Chittenden
prize is awarded annually for the senior
majoring in the Natural Sciences or in
mathematics who ranks highest in
scholarship this year's prize is awarded
to Lionel Jin of Grace Hopper college
Lionel Jin was awarded yells Hartman
Lyman prize last year as the junior with
the best record of intellectual and
social accomplishment he was named to
Phi Beta Kappa for his junior year and
he graduates summa [ __ ] laude with a
joint master's degree in molecular
cellular and developmental biology and
was distinction in both the intensive
track of molecular biology and in
computer science
I do
but Lionel was recently selected as a
Schwartzman scholar and after graduation
he plans to work in the technology
industry and build products that will
transform the way we live in recognition
of his extraordinary record and his
promise of future success Yale College
proudly confers the Russell Henry
Chittenden prize this year upon lion
Elgin
[Applause]
Jr and Troy will you please come up to
the stage
the Alphaeus henry snow prize is awarded
to that senior who through the
combination of intellectual achievement
character and personality shall be
adjudged by the faculty to have done the
most real by inspiring in his or her
classmates an admiration and love for
the best traditions of high scholarship
this year the snow prize is awarded to
June Yantra of Sabre College
[Applause]
- joonyoung cha graduate summa [ __ ] laude
with exceptional distinction in his
major history yen has received the
Harvard Curtis prize for excellence in
English a ten Duyck prize for public
speaking and an invitation by Sterling
Memorial Library
to curate the exhibit sociologists with
a conscience
Raymond Kennedy and the making of the
global United States yen's instructors
agree that he has deeply researched and
powerfully argued papers on the history
of colonial regulation in Singapore the
country of his birth
South Africa and more broadly the
British Empire and the Chinese diaspora
have made stunningly original history or
graphic interventions whose significance
is unheard of for an undergraduate as a
first-year counselor in sabra he has
supported new undergraduates helping
them make their place at Yale in his
last column as opinion editor for the
Yale Daily News he encouraged future
jelly's to think of themselves as being
in time as recognizing how the past
shapes them and how they shape the
present and the future his contributions
to broader communities are about to
begin but for those he has made to you
Yale College takes great pleasure in
bestowing the Alphaeus Henry snow prize
upon joon-young
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
president Salome Dean Chun Secretary
Clinton esteemed administrators and
faculty Yale friends and family and
members of the class of 2018 the day has
finally come
we are proud to be here delivering the
valedictory address
we're not the valedictorians what you
got a D in medical Spanish that was one
flub okay you barely passed a class
called Vikings exclamation point how did
you know that question mark you took a
class called plants and people and you
still can't tell which is which
that's enough you talking ficus anyway
we are just here as two members of the
senior class offering our reflections on
four remarkable years at Yale okay yes
and although we're getting ready to
leave this place has provided us with
some things that will last us long after
college indelible memories unforgettable
experiences and amazing relationships
but these things can't last forever
I'm sorry what as our four bright
college years draw to a close we as the
class of 2018 now prepare for a new
journey life after graduation will be
daunting but we will face these new
opportunities head on head on together
together in a sense but in another sense
decidedly apart what is happening
we're here today to recognize that as we
prepare to take the next steps in our
young adult lives we may find ourselves
moving away from the ties we made on
this campus hey is there something you
want to talk about there is Oh God and
that thing is Yale oh good
and how Yale is a metaphor for our
relationship Oh shedding light on our
four years here it's clear that we've
grown as individuals we loved Yale but
like any love it eventually comes time
to say goodbye
the new chapter is beckoning I thought
but still in many ways we should keep we
should keep that old chapter with us
right I mean we really liked the old
chapter it was great
College whoo-hoo Ben
right
[Applause]
Yale was wonderful and while we'll
always cherish the memories we made here
we must also make room in our hearts for
the journeys ahead and just to play
devil's advocate for a second we don't
uh we don't have to stop loving Yale as
we take the next step everyone's like Oh
Yale you're so wonderful we love how
you're always singing and dancing and
how good you look in blue and you look
forward to new horizons I mean they'll
might not be the most well endowed but
it is up there
we just we've we need to open ourselves
to new opportunities exactly what new
opportunities do you really do you it
sort of seems like you do it in front of
Hilary listen
listen we need to flirt there we go
various professional fields okay okay we
need to embrace your new embrace the
uncertainty of being a post-grad in
today's worlds true okay and we need to
let ourselves be seduced
who is it is it onder's the football
stars the football yes I I called it
look Yale was an incredible part of our
lives but now it's time to go our minds
are made up and we're ready to go well I
guess there's not much left to say maybe
we should leave Yale behind maybe these
four years are just a time for us to
look back on but you know what as I look
out on this sea of potted plants
I'm realizing that I'm not ready to give
up on Yale and you shouldn't be either
so I'm gonna win her back the only way I
know how by continuing to extend this
already played out metaphor
Yale is like any relationship or any
friendship think back to when you were
first seeking it out and hoping and
hoping it would happen think about the
way it finally came to be and changed
you and shaped you and allowed you to
shape it in turn think about the way
that this class in particular shaped
Yale back challenging it to be warmer
and brighter than it was when you first
met so don't give up on Yale don't leave
these days behind and when you're
looking back years
[Applause]
is she right behind me with onder's the
football star
I mean yeah I get it
here's to the class of 2018
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Sarah
Armstrong and I am the secretary for the
class of 2018 I'm Julia Feldstein and
I'm the treasurer for the class of 2018
today we celebrate traditions that have
been performed by thousands of
undergraduates who have come before us
these traditions link us to almost two
centuries of Yale graduates when class
day began there were about as many
seniors then as there are now in one of
the smaller residential colleges on the
day before commencement in 1869 all the
seniors sat in a circle they sang songs
read poems heard nostalgic and amusing
talks and at the end of the day smoked
clay pipes together seniors if you look
in your gift bags you will find a clay
pipe without tobacco to keep us a link
to the past and a memento of this day
and we know what you're thinking
these pipes would be great for blowing
bubbles we agree and we included some
bubble solution in the bag beginning in
1851 graduating classes have also
planted a sprig of ivy somewhere on
campus symbolic of the enduring nature
of the friendships made at Yale
this year's Ivy was printed on Phelps
gate nearby the engraved stone that
bears our classier both the ivy and the
stone will be a reminder of the class of
2018 for those entering and leaving
campus this year we continue a more
recent tradition started in 2011 seniors
each of you have been given in your Biff
gift bag and anthology a short
collection of works written by our peers
this booklet contains the ODEs and
speeches you hear from our classmates
today as well as those written by the
finalists for these positions the
booklet honors them and serves as
memories of our break College years
before today's festivity
and with the singing of our alma mater
and the waving of white handkerchiefs we
will view a twist on an old tradition
since 2007 the class history has been
delivered as a short film rather than a
series of speeches written produced and
directed by our peers a copy of this
short film which speaks to change at
Yale will be preserved in the
collections of the by Nike library and
of course can be found on youtube today
we pay homage to the rich traditions
that characterize this exciting time in
our lives we hope that you enjoy these
traditions that they strengthen the ties
between friends and serve as a reminder
for the experiences we have shared we
also want to thank you all for really
making Yale feel like more of a home
than a school Julie and I have been
involved in class-wide events since our
first year and every time our community
comes together we are blown away by how
deeply our classmates care about each
other and how much fun we have together
we can't wait to see these friendships
continue to grow and thrive after
graduation we're already planning the
five year reunion we begin now with the
Ivy ode in older days that ode was a
poem in Latin sapphic stanzas as the
world of poetry has extended so have the
forms and subject-matter of the Ivy ODEs
today odd web why do we'll read her
spoken word poem the fractal salutation
[Applause]
let us hail everything that shattered
yes
hail to everything that shattered hail
to the day we realize how truly big the
world was the day we learned the
magnitude of 7 billion hail to the
Dawn's that bled to dusk and once more
to dawn and hail to little we could show
for them hail to the destruction of our
brilliance hail to the disbelief the
horrid shock that we weren't as immune
to failure as we believed hail are some
earnest to accept it hail to every
unspoken word we suppressed and hail to
every spoken word we mishandled hail to
the dreams we were so close to the ones
our fingers were lucky enough to touch
just before they were ripped out of our
hands
hail to the inevitable periods of
smallness hail to every time we fought
to be heard and were smothered and
blocked out and overshadowed why you may
ask am i pressing a salted thumb on the
wounds we choose to bury to suffocate to
forget why am i forcing to lights the
choice open secrets that we were never
always truly happy I can only answer
this by asking you who do you think you
would be without the pain hail to the
adults that we are
though we may deny it hail to the faces
only brightened by the tears that trace
them hail to the forgiveness I can only
make sense by knowing anger hail to the
voices that have been strengthened
because they felt silence hail to the
sweetness of success that
needed to follow failure my friends
hail to us all our kaleidoscopic
collection that has learned to walk by
light and truth and hail to the world
that we hope will soon be ready for us
thank you hello class of 2018 I'm Alec
Rodrigues and I'm the producer of the
class day film this year and our film is
titled perfect timing on behalf of all
of the crew and cast we hope you enjoy
it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
today high of 49 in cloudy tonight lows
31 clouding of Laurel high bridge for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
October 19th 1978 equations are almost
done and meeting with advisor at 3:30
and oh oh crap
Carmen drogas theoretical physicist out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for mr. Stephens I'm so sorry I didn't
realize that you're 20 minutes late or
that your senior thesis is absurd time
travel
this isn't Harvard we don't do
half-baked pseudoscience here at the
psychology department that's beside the
point you would need a massive
intergalactic disruption to create a
wormhole of that magnitude giving you
one week to come up with another
proposal thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Applause]
[Music]
Dylan 78 should have credit deed kind of
intro that's out
[Music]
over five million of the over 15 million
books in Yale's library collection so a
lot a lot of books but before we head
inside and check it on the interior do
you want to check see if you guys have
any questions that can help with um what
year is it I'm sorry um what year are
you oh I'm a senior I'm class of 2018
[Music]
welcome to Yale where students get a
world-class education
I just want to piggyback off what I just
said but I'd really like to hone in on a
Saturday job no this is Pauli Murray
College who's Paul Murray
no no Polly Murray she's a civil rights
activist and the first black woman to
have a residential college named after
that's incredible
um who's the other one named after Oh
comment kind of it's called the
Schwartzman Center now imagine that
let's go and that concludes our tour
does anyone have any last questions what
[Music]
so you're telling me that you traveled
from 1978 using a time machine from your
senior essay
powered by a comet got stuck in 2018 and
ripped a hole in the space-time
continuum that's now gonna consume all
of Yale yes and why should I believe you
because if you don't
Yale will be destroyed I need to figure
out how to jumpstart my time machine and
reverse this black hole
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
professor Stevens was right I can't I
can't do this you traveled 40 years in
the future I mean if you can do that you
can fix this no I don't think so I've
I've tried everything I think that we
need to warn people before it's too late
excuse me we need to see the president
immediate to meet with the president you
have to schedule a meeting at least two
months in advance Vee I'm listen it's a
matter of life and death
Yale is going to be destroyed well then
you need to send a formal request to the
Committee on cosmic catastrophes which
will send their final decision to the
committee to establish principles on
preventing cosmic catastrophes I have an
idea
between wl8 in two hours
[Music]
[Music]
professor Stephen I'm sorry my office
Houser comment rudest I've been
expecting you for a long time but I
didn't know where in time you'd land
I jumped 40 years and I think that it
opened some kind of black hole and I see
one possible solution one kilogram of
active shallow vain iam which is a rare
and highly unstable isotope might be
able to jumpstart your time machine and
move the black hole to a different
special location you mean I mean push it
somewhere else preferably to a dark and
desolate and cold and irrelevant corner
of the universe okay I know what I need
to do um quick question though uh can I
get your thesis is 40 years late okay
totally understand oh also where do I
can salivate I mean it's obvious isn't
it mr. president it really needs top
young lady you okay it's okay let her in
Peter salivate bluegrass legend woody oh
um sorry mr. president
I need salivate a.m. so that I can save
Yale from being swallowed up from a
massive black hole you can have it
but under one condition
[Music]
we don't have time for this we're in
time I second that
how can you but pop I study brief
without Papa I'm sorry I lied there's no
Popeyes I called you all here because
yell as we know it will cease to exist
yeah a giant black hole is going to
destroy all of Yale and the rest of the
world I guess so yeah I will never get
into med school now oh let's grab a meal
before Yale is completely destroyed MIT
Cal real quick so how about this
Saturday yeah yeah so sorry no I have a
cappella reach me that day Sunday yeah
we can have society I'm so sorry how
about I just send you a doodle Paul
instead is that okay okay I'll see you
hey guys I'm here with the Yale Daily
News and I was hoping to get a quick
comment on the impending doom
[Music]
black hole oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
no no no bill it's fine we are okay
what we wanted to announce instead is
that of Peter cow maze bluegrass band
will be playing Saturday at College
Street Music Hall and tickets go online
today
it was salivating him all along highly
powerful radioactive isotope well this
is it
you saved Yale yeah just have to fire up
the time machine and it should reverse
the black hole then I'll see you in 40
years when you're a Nobel Peace Prize
winner yeah it'd be much easier if I got
to stay in 2018 what do you mean don't
worry about it
[Music]
[Music]
may eleventh 1975 freshman year has been
a rush I've been meeting so many new
people from all over the country and all
over the world I can't believe I get to
call this place my home for three more
years
[Music]
Yale isn't perfect but I have a feeling
me my friends are gonna change it and
the world maybe you're busy being a
world-famous physicist now and don't
remember any of this but I hope this
feeling never wore off
[Music]
this is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations class of 2018
congratulations class of 2018 we're here
we're waiting for you welcome arms and
hope congratulations on a listen you've
taken the test you take in to the exams
may relationships you've broken up
you've had your card swell you've had it
and you've done everything now what's
left is graduate
really ever again
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone please take out your white
handkerchiefs and rise to join us in
yells alma mater Brite college years
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the memories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is it on